Sarah Swift got a speeding ticket on her
way from home from work if she pays her
fine now there will be no added penalty
if she delays her payment then a penalty
will be assessed for the number of
months T that she delays paying her fine
her total fine F in euros is indicated
in the table below these numbers
represent an exponential an exponential
function so they give us the number of
months that the payment is delayed and
then the amount of fine and this should
be this is essentially data points from
an exponential function just to remind
ourselves what an exponential function
would look like this tells us that our
fine as our function of the months
delayed is going to be equal to some
number times some common ratio to the T
power
this infer this telling us this
exponential function is essentially
telling us that our function is going to
have this form right over here
so let's see if we can answer their
questions so the first question is what
is the common ratio of consecutive
values of F so the the the the reason
why are right over here is called is
called the common ratio is it's the
ratio that if you look at any to say if
you were to increment T by one the ratio
of that to F of T that ratio is should
be consistent for any T so let me give
you an example here the ratio the ratio
of f of 2 to f of 1 should be equal to
the ratio of F of 3 to F of 2 which
should be the same as the ratio of F of
4 to F of 3 or in general terms the
ratio of f of t plus 1 to the ratio of F
of T should be equal to all of these
things that would be the common ratio so
let's see what that is if we just look
at the form if we just look at this
right over here so what's the ratio of F
of 2 to F of 1 450 divided by 300 well
that's one point five that's one point
five six hundred seventy five divided by
450 that's one point five one thousand
twelve divided by point
5/6 7 675 that's one point five so the
common ratio in all of these situations
is one point five so the common ratio
over here is one point five and another
way and just two and just to make it
clear why this our right over here is
called the common ratio is let's just do
this general form so f of T plus one
well that's just going to be that's just
going to be a times R to the T plus one
power and F of T is a times R to the T
power so what is this going to be this
is going to be let's see this is going
to be R to the T plus 1 minus T which is
just going to be equal to R to the first
power which is just equal to R so this
term this this this variable R is going
to be equal to this common ratio so when
we figured out that the common ratio is
1.5 that tells us that our function is
going to be of the form f of T is equal
to a times instead of writing an R there
we now know that R is 1.5 to the T power
1.5 to the T power write a formula for
this function well we've almost done
that but we haven't figured out what a
is and to figure out what a is we could
just substitute we know what F of 1 is
when T is equal to 1 F is equal to 300
and so we should be able to use that
information to solve for a we could have
used any of these data points to solve
for a but let's do that F of 1 is equal
to a times 1.5 to the first power or a
times 1.5 and that is going to be equal
to they tell us that F of 1 is equal to
300 and so another way of writing this
is we could say 1.5 times a is equal to
300 divide both sides by 1 point 5 and
we get a is equal to a is equal to 200
and so our function our formula for our
function is let me write it in black so
we can see it is going to be 200 that's
our a times 1.5 to the T power now
another way well actually let's just
think about the
next question what is the fine and euros
for Sarah speeding ticket if she pays it
on time so paying it on time that
implies that T is equal to zero or
another way of thinking about it we need
to figure out her fine for T equals zero
so we need to figure out F of zero so
what's F of zero one point it's 200
times one point five to the zero power
one point five to the zero power is one
so that's just going to be equal to
equal to 200 euro now another way of
thinking about it is well let's look at
the common ratio to go from 675 to 450
you're essentially dividing by the
common ratio to go from 450 to 300 you
are dividing by the common ratio so then
to go to from to go from T equals 1 at T
equals 0 you would divide by the common
ratio again and you would get 2 you
would get to 200 or another way of
thinking about it is to go to successive
values or successive months every time
we are multiplying by the common ratio
every time we are multiplying we are
multiplying by the common ratio